jennifer lawrence is pregnant oh well
that's very nice yep she and husband
cook maroney are expecting their first
child together a rep for the oscar
winner confirmed the happy news on
wednesday yeah it's gonna be it's gonna
be phenomenal the couple has made it a
point to keep their relationship private
rarely being photographed or attending
public events together jennifer and cook
were first linked to each other in 2018.
the actress and the art dealer became
engaged the following february later
tying the knot in fall of that year and
here's a sweet moment jennifer gushed to
e.t about her future husband a few
months before the big day why is cook
the one why is he the one that made you
say uh um throwing that away um well
he's just the best person i've ever met
my whole life it was it was a very easy
easy decision
can i get that one more ice water and
i'll get two more glasses of white wine
and i don't need the judgy face and what
about this jennifer's big news drops the
same day as the trailer for her new
movie don't look up
your breathing is stressing me out this
will affect the entire planet and this
film has an enormous celebrity ensemble
teeing up a potentially star-studded
baby shower for the expectant mother you
know i don't want to go anywhere
[Music]